here's the Prime Minister Saad Hariri
and let's listen it had 13 days ago the
Lebanese people have been waiting for a
political solution that put an end to
the deteriorating situation throughout
this period have been trying to find an
exit through which we can listen to
people's voices and steer our country
away from any political economical or
any other threats today with all the
great we have reached a deadlock and we
need a shock in order to break through
the crisis I'm heading to the
presidential palace to render down the
resignation of the government to the
excellencies president mashiro and to
the Lebanese people wherever they are
this is in response to the well and
demand of thousands of the police who
took to the streets demanding change it
is based on our duty to provide a
network and it's a safety net to protect
the entire country from plunging into
may I call on all the Lebanese to give
precedence and priority to Lebanon's
stability unity and civil peace and to
steal the country away from the economic
crunch and our political partners I say
it is our duty today together to
safeguard Lebanon and to steer it away
from any pearls it is our duty to bring
our economy back on its feet in a
genuine stance that we shouldn't be
wasted
I will render my resignation and I will
place it under the disposal of the
president and all the Lebanese offices
come and go however our country must
live on intact no one is above Lebanon
may God save Lebanon may Lebanon live on
a very short very short statement there
from Prime Minister Saad Hariri in
Lebanon he said that he was on his way
to the presidential palace to tender the
resignation of the government and his
own resignation do we have a ahora back
with us
yes Zahra hora is out on the streets of
Beirut
Zana first of all before we get to the
reaction what the likely reactions that
is going to be what what are we to make
of what side hurriediy has just done
well he has resigned it was a demand by
the protesters they wanted the
government to resign the ruling elite to
be replaced by technocrats you don't
have any political affiliation in order
to carry out much-needed economic reform
so he is heeding the demand of those who
were in in the streets now what this
means there's a political crisis in the
country a vacuum now that he has
resigned what is going to happen next he
blamed his partners yet again because
this is the second time he addressed me
nation since the protest movement began
13 days ago the first time he blamed his
partners in the government for not
allowing him or obstructing his work he
wasn't able to carry out reforms and he
gave them three days 72 hours to try to
come up with a solution they came up
with an economic reform package but it
wasn't enough for the people on the
ground now he says I'm trying I was
trying to find an exit to the crisis and
what is needed is a shock there is no
doubt the Prime Minister resigning is a
shock trying to find an exit to the
crisis he has been holding talks with
ministers representing the different
parties over the past few days his
partners in government yes he calls them
partners but he is not a member of the
ruling Alliance he is in the opposition
it's a very complicated picture but one
has to mention this those who are in
control of government those who are in
control of Parliament is an alliance
that is made up of the president the
House Speaker and Hezbollah they control
the government and Parliament but they
need him they need Sadaharu he is the
main Sunni leader in this country and
this is a country where the political
system is based on sectarian
sectarianism so the main Sunday leader
of the country resigning means a whole
community has now been sidelined and I
think this is what Heidi is trying there
is betting on hoping that this will put
pressure on his quote/unquote partners
to compromise to find a consensus to
come up with a with a government that
will be acceptable to people on the
streets because at the end of the day
Hezbollah the Hezbollah
it's needs hadiri he gives them
political cover the international
community supports him if they appoint a
prime minister who is allied to them
there is a very big chance that the
Lebanese government will not gain their
legitimacy in the international
community already already the United
States has been imposing sanctions on a
main player in the government the
Iranian backed Hezbollah so if this
government becomes purely a Hezbollah
backed LED government then Lebanon as a
country could be sanctioned by the US so
he knows this these are the cards that
saddl Hariri has in his hands he's
playing them playing them maybe it is a
negotiating tactic but right now his
decision is it's decided with the
protesters in the streets I would say
that for the moment many thanks indeed
let's go elsewhere in the city al
Jazeera Stephanie Decker is in Beirut
Stephanie you can't see the pictures
that we're showing our viewers at the
moment scenes of what can only be
described as a celebration after the the
violence scenes we saw earlier in the
day protesters pretty happy they've got
what they wanted the government is no
more does that mean an end to the
protests what happens next I think it's
very early days we are outside the
residence of the Prime Minister you saw
earlier things in this country can
change in a second
we saw the violence of supporters
achieve the main duties you heard say in
a report there he's now tendered his
resignation we have had warnings as well
of a power vacuum in this country what
happens now well the political parties
in Parliament will need to head for
consultations with the president this
can take time that a name needs to be
decided of course it needs to be a Sunni
leader according to the Constitution
this again can take time and then they
need to form a cabinet whoever that
person is so you are heading into times
of uncertainty here so there may be
celebrations but as people will tell you
there are many different parties that
have many different interests on the
ground this is a country that is
incredibly well-armed you have parties
that have militias attached to them the
population in general the majority of
them have weapons at home it is a
concern I mean just earlier before this
speech
and we saw people in our building
leaving their offices early going home
of course there's there's a question
mark people are nervous as to how this
is going to play out they haven't been
here before in terms of this exact way
of course Lebanon has had political
crises before it's had no government
before it's had no real leader before
but now the people yes they said they
wanted the entire government to resign I
think it is a welcome first step of
course because as you heard from the
Prime Minister there he was directly
addressing the people saying this is a
response to what you wanted and he also
ventured his political partners we know
that there's been bickering between the
sides not agreeing as to what he wanted
saying that it is our duty to safeguard
Lebanon so again I think it's too early
days to predict everyone we've been
speaking to over the last almost two
weeks now will tell you it's very
difficult to predict how things are
going to go on people would say they
didn't see a resignation of the
government that has now happened on
certain times in Lebanon they can be
dangerous times as you saw on the
streets earlier today things changed in
the second supporters of those two main
movements the a bowel movement and
Hezbollah clashed with protesters moved
on to martyrs square started slashing
down the tents police came in a little
late to try and disperse them so
anything is possible these are uncertain
times now let's wait and see how things
are going to play out yes people are
celebrating but I think certainly two
early days for any kind of jubilation
there are major challenges ahead one
thing you haven't mentioned Stephanie is
whether they will there will have to be
election now I mean that the government
has essentially collapsed the Prime
Minister is going to president Owen to
tender his and his resignation and that
of the government you say that the
president will now a encourage the
various parties to try to form another
government
yes elections is something that the
protesters want but the protesters
demands are or that they now there is an
interim government cabinet made up of
technocrats individuals who are not
linked to any of the political parties
of course the protesters have been
calling also for a change to the
municipal system a political system that
has been engraved here for decades these
are huge challenges huge asks so what
they want is of a government interim
government of technocrats independent
people until new elections are going to
be called is that going to happen
we don't know certainly at the moment we
heard from the Prime Minister he's
heading to the palace to tender his
resignation to the president then we're
going to have to wait and see what is
going to happen next whether those
demands are going to be addressed or
whether and again this is going to take
time we're talking weeks and weeks down
the line potentially this is not gonna
have an answer tomorrow what is gonna
happen on the streets earlier today we
were hearing reports that the protesters
were going to regain their momentum in
response to those counter protests that
we saw earlier today and returning to
the streets I think at the moment
everything is still up in the air as to
how this is going to play out of course
the protesters are welcoming this but
because of the political dynamics in
this country they are incredibly
complicated they are not only internal
they are linked to the entire region
they are linked to Saudi Arabia they are
linked to Iran they are linked to other
countries it is an incredibly complex
web of allegiances that play each other
out there are you know positions of
power in play that do not want to lose
those kinds of positions that they have
achieved over time so big question marks
this is a country that can be very
volatile so I think too early to be able
to predict anything at this point in
time but certainly a demand of the
protesters one government resigned we've
now seen that happen to transitional
government of independent technocrats is
that going to happen and three early
elections I think we're gonna have to
wait and see time will tell how things
gonna play out here al Jazeera Stephanie
Decker live there in Beirut that news
once again Lebanon's prime minister Saud
Hariri says he's reached a dead end and
will submit his resignation
the president this is him speaking just
a few moments ago